JK No loop Sorry, I was a mistake.
I I was actually listening to the Playback video.
I had tab open of it and I was listening to that instead of the Instead of like my actual OBS so I was like wait, that's not right.
Oh shit.
Let me it Chad's broken too.
Oh my god I'm so happy.
This is over.
I can stop crying about this
My god, I'm just happy it's over like I the last week of this Okay story time.
Okay.
It's not really story time but like We'll have chat here because I don't care But like basically like The last week for this event was absolute hell because everything that could go wrong Basically went wrong.
We had so many we had to use a lot of back last-minute backups and stuff like that and everything and I'm just half like I like obviously there was a lot there was like, you know Things we could improve on and stuff like that.
Like it was a huge learning experience There's a lot of stuff I could improve on for next time if I ever want to do something like semi-competitive You know, I try to push the casual it was still Competitive in a way that you know, there were pros in it.
I know like I okay So, um, let me talk about the behind the scenes for this because I know some people are wondering I actually got emails about this too because they're like, why did you invite pros?
It's supposed to be an all v2 raven.
I think I talked about before but if I didn't get the pros involved We wouldn't have had the event in the first place.
We did not have enough player
Because um, because there was an issue regarding like a lot of teams, especially in especially in like More well-known teams and Really wanted to join this custom because of the fact that we had the op they had the opportunity to play with the The like play with one of their like professional player like the play with professional players that they've never had a chance to play With before or like this is like their first time or like for JP teams.
This is their first time being able to fight alongside NA pros or like EU pros or being able to play with professional players on the other side of the world.
So Because of that that really helped a lot in terms of like gathering Players, especially the ones that have like have like a reputation amongst like the community regarding like Like like I guess like wow factor like this was like the uniqueness of this custom and the uniqueness of the custom to be able to like Have a chance to play with these types of more players and also it put more eyes on the event itself In regards to like maybe people who don't normally watch vtubers this is like their introduction to vtubers because a lot of you guys might not realize this but The Apex community within the NA side is not very well known.
It is not very popular, I would say, for like people in NA side or like English-speaking side to watch Vtubers.
And especially those who watch Apex in general too.
So it was more so the way to bring more eyes, especially to the JP side and the NA Vtuber side and everything.
So that was why, like, it was like, because originally I know some people were like, oh, I thought you were gonna make an all Vtuber custom.
But if I try to make an all Vtuber custom, like, it wouldn't have been able to get off the ground in general, because like, we couldn't get enough like players in terms of like balancing out the JP Apex side and the NA side.
And also being able to have like the amount of like, I guess, like, what's the word?
Like have enough star power in there that we would have interest from sponsors and have interest from outside communities as well to watch this event.
Because this is my, like, this is like the first one too.
So we also have to remember that this is like the first time I did these types of events and stuff.
So like, it was, I wanted to have a splash in it too.
So like, there will be eyes on this event in regards to having it so that people would be like, oh, this is, this is a curious thing.
And of course, this is my first time organizing it.
So it was incredibly rough.
It was incredibly rough getting 60 people to agree with each other.
So yeah, so it was incredibly rough getting 60 people there.
We had some last minute,
like I cried almost every day because I had to fix a fire that was going on.
Like, it was a huge struggle making this work.
And, and I'm really happy that in the end it's over.
And, and that even as a first event, I would say that it was, it was like, I want to say pretty successful because we did have like issues regarding balancing issues.
But like, we did the best we could as the first event from three people trying to make it work.
And like, obviously there's a lot to improve on.
There's a lot I can improve on for next time.
Because I said a first event is, every event I plan is a new hurdle I have to learn and a new hurdle that I have to learn to do because like WrestleTuber has improved from his previous iteration because I learned from it.
Like every iteration I get better at like hosting specific types of events.
So I hope if I ever do another competitive event, I can learn from this one on how to balance it more properly and how to like figure out the schematics for it.
I wouldn't have been able to do this without, um, without Tempo's help and Dash's help.
Dash for like translating everything on, like translating everything, um, and like helping me with communicating with uh the JP side.
He got paid for it.
I mean, he's gonna get paid.
I haven't paid him yet.
I pay, I'm gonna be paying him.
I'll pay him with the money I won from, you know, like I won the last game.
Um, so I'll pay him from the money I got to keep from the last game.
And Tempo for, he literally did the paperwork for the sponsor within a day, um, to get it all running and everything.
So like a huge shout out to Tempo.
Um, it wasn't even originally gonna be sponsored.
Um, this event wasn't even originally gonna be sponsored.
We managed to secure, well, I was very persistent because I was like, hey, yay, ha ha ha, like this is gonna be a pre.
This is also why, um, I try to make it like have some, I try to balance it out with like having some star power in there and also like, um, giving chance to other indies or other smaller companies and stuff.
Um, a chance to, uh, um, to be part of it as well.
Um, but it does help regarding getting sponsors.
So we didn't have sponsors at first, but when we finally got the team list of everybody, um, um, like we managed to secure a sponsor with like EA, um, within like last minute.
And that's why like we didn't announce it when we first announced it because it was all negotiating and everything.
So, um, I was like being like, hey EA, ha ha.
I'll be like, I'll be like, knock knock EA.
Hey, like I'm doing this.
Are you sure you don't wanna, you know, and then like no reply.
And I'll be like, hey EA, I'm doing this.
I'm still doing this.
Um, and like, you know, here's like stuff I organized and here's like all the information.
And then like, no, I don't really hear anything.
And I'll be like, knock, knock.
Ha ha.
Hey, I know I just messaged you yesterday about this, but I'm going to message you again.
And then EA's like, you know what?
Yeah, let's do it.
And I'm like, thank you.
I'm like, thank you so much.
Oh my God.
I really, I really appreciate it.
I'm so sorry for being, I'm so sorry for the spam, but I really appreciate it.
Um, oh my God.
Um, but yeah, I really appreciated like, uh, um, EA for sponsoring the prize pool and everything and like potentially working with them in the future.
Cause they, we talked about it, like MeTempo and you were talking about it and how, um, they were like wondering, would I like to do more events in the future with them?
Um, for next year, for 2025, obviously like from this, this is like my pilot episode.
Um, there's definitely a lot more I can improve on.
Um, I definitely are gonna look, the reason why there was no rank limit is because some, some VTubers don't have like people they know that can fit the rank requirement.
So that's why I was just like, well, on JP's side is very easy.
It's incredibly easy for them to find another master players or another Pred player.
Um, but in NA side, it was very difficult for teams to be able to find players that are like masters and Preds as well.
So, um, so it was very difficult.
So that's why I had to go with no rank limit because if I give them a rank limit, um, they won't be able to like, able to fit this requirement.
So like at that point I was just like, okay, we'll just, we'll have to go with no rank limit because, um, that's why we, it was very difficult for like both sides to be able to like adjust to it.
And with that, I went with the mindset where like, I'll just nerf the really good teams as we go along.
Um, yeah.
And, uh, I'll just be like, I'll just, we'll just like, uh, we'll just nerf the teams, uh, as we go along.
Uh, so like that we could like balance it out as the games go on.
And that's why I was like pushing Greek and Wig to be like, Hey, let's do some nerfs.
And we're like, let's buff some teams and stuff like that.
Um, and we, we had, we wanted to push the more casual aspect, but of course it is harder to push the casual aspect when we have like, um, you know, when it's like, uh, uh, lots of different skill levels are involved.
And I'm, I'm happy that, um, I, I did send personal apologies to the teams that had it rough the most.
Um, because I did feel really bad.
I was like, I wanted everyone to have like a good experience.
So I did feel bad for the teams that did have, cause like, you know, there's 20 teams.
There has to be teams that are like 20th place or 19th place or 18th place.
Like it's a, it's a, it's a custom, but it still has competitive factors in there.
So like, I just send some personal apologies to teams that were like placed at the bottom.
Um, because of course, like I wanted them to have fun, um, and everything.
So, um, I just send like personal apologies and stuff to them and hope that I was like in my next big event, I hope you, that you guys are, um, willing to join my next event.
And like, it's more the next event I'm planning on is less skill-based.
I'm not like planning it at the moment.
Like, I mean, it is sort of semi-planned.
I have a team running for it.
Like the team on standby work, that's going to be working on it when they've done with their next pro last project.
Well, cause they're this like team that I have, they do like other stuff for other people.
So, um, like, like the, regarding the, what event I'm doing, they've, they have, they've done it before for others.
So, um, they have a, they have a, you know, schedule.
So like they're taking mine in like 2025.
So like, uh, I will be, it's going to be less competitive base.
It's going to be all VTubers, um, for this next one.
And, uh, so, uh, this is like the next, that's my next.
And I still told, I apologize to the team.
I was like, I would love to have you guys like back again, um, for this next event that I'm doing.
Um, but it's more so like, it's not like this, the one in the apex one is more so of like, it's more, um, like it's definitely we're pushing the casual up more.
Um, we're definitely, uh, pushing the casual aspect more for the next one because this one was more competitive.
This one was like semi-competitive, but the next one will be, we're going to try to push the casual aspect for it next time.
Um, um, but always tempo in chat.
Where is he?
I don't see him cause I know he's not subscribed.
So I'm trying to look for a, a gray name.
Wait, not subscribe.
No, he's not a member.
Uh, only seven teams per game storm point only apex car.
These can only shoot.
Oh my God.
Oh, that's crazy.
The thing is we can only have seven teams.
The entire tournament would just be seven teams.
What are we going to do with the other seven?
I mean,
we could have it, so that we have three lobbies going on three lobbies going on like, like BLGS, we have like several lobbies going on and then like, Oh my God, that'd be crazy.
Um, but yeah, um, he has asked, has asked us if we're open to, uh, like looking into like doing more customs, um, in the future for apex.
So that's something for like tempo and I to look into in the future in 2025.
Um, no, no, no.
Thank you for the 10 gift.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Um, um, but I hope EA likes it tempo.
I hope EA liked the event.
I hope they like watch the event too.
Um, um, so, um, yeah, it'll be, uh, really, uh, it's like, you know, I learned a lot for this and I, I really appreciate everybody for participating.
Um, everyone for participating, all the teams I invited, all the people that applied to be invited, um, a huge shout out.
And, um, you know, I tried to make sure everybody's wish came true because like I said, I heard, uh, QP was a huge fan of nice wig.
And, um, you know, I know I said like only winners who get to have a chance to talk to wig, but I know that, Oh wait, check discord DM.
That's funny.
Oh, wow.
That's pretty.
Um, yeah.
Um, um, but yeah, that's the, yeah.
Do I say it?
Tempo am I allowed to say it?
Is that fucked if I say it?
Will it, will it hurt?
Will it hurt us if I say it?
Tempo, I need to know.
Tempo, please.
You're not typing back.
Tempo, you're not typing back.
See what?
Well, I don't know.
This is Tempo's decision.
If I say it or not, maybe not say it.
Okay.
I can't say it.
He's like, don't know.
Maybe don't.
Okay.
We'll never know.
Just, um, but yes, I'm glad people really enjoyed it.
Um, I always want people to have fun.
I'm glad viewers, I'm glad viewers and players had a great time and everything.
Like I said, for, like I said, um, I knew QP was a huge fan of Wig.
So like, even though, like they didn't win, I know they were, our PR was trying really hard to help QP win, help QP and Suna win so that they have a chance to interact with Wig.
So that's why like, you know, I gave up my interview slot because I talked to Wig anyway.
So like all the time.
So it's like, like me and Jen, like we've talked to Wig a lot.
So like for us, we're like, okay, I don't know.
I don't know if Altair even cares to be fair.
I don't think Altair cares about the interview.
So I was just like, I know I should have asked Altair.
So I was like, I don't mind giving up our slot to like, you know, have a chance for like our PRs, QP and Suna to talk to Wig.
Cause this is like, you know, the first time they were able to actually interact with him, like directly.
So that's why I like, just try to make sure that everybody had a great time or had like enjoyed their experience.
Cause this is the first time, you know, ShibuyaHal has been organizing VSychio for like what, six years now?
Is it six years?
No, not six years.
It's Apex, it's not even six years.
Is it?
It's season six, right?
Like he's had like season six of VSychio and he has like an entire fucking team and everything.
Is Apex six years old?
I can't remember.
I know like this is, he's like four years.
Wait, four to five.
Like I know he's like season six, right?
Of VSychio.
Um, but like four years, four years of VSychio.
Oh my God.
Really?
Four years of VSychio?
How many seasons has VSychio had though?
I thought it was more, but he, you know, he has an entire team and he has like some, I have to start somewhere.
Oh yeah.
Six, yeah.
It was like six VSychio seasons.
So like, you know, his first VSychio, you know, it was the first time and he keeps building it up more and more.
Um, this is basically me first time.
I hope to build it up more and more regarding events in the future.
Um, and learn from my mistakes and try to get better at it as I go along.
And, um, yeah, he has like, he has 30 people.
It was me, Tempo, and Dash.
It's not a competition.
We definitely, we definitely needed more people.
Um, we will definitely, we learn.
Oh my God.
Um, but yes, like definitely want to improve more so of hosting events.
Like Tempo has a lot of experience with hosting events.
And then I have some experience doing like Apex, not Apex, VTuber events.
So we like combined our, um, combined like what we know together and everything.
I, I like yelled and raged at Tempo so much the last week, not at him.
I was raging and he gets to see like the ugly side of me.
Tempo's like, you got to stop stressing out.
And then I was like, no, I'm going to fucking, I'm gonna cry.
I'm gonna cry.
I'm gonna have a breakdown.
I'm gonna break down Tempo.
I fucking hate this.
I'm going to have a fucking breakdown.
And then Tempo was super fucking chill.
Um, you know, I went so Manhera.
No, you guys don't understand.
I was super Manhera throughout all of this.
Like I begged not, okay.
I not, okay.
I don't know why I say beg is the right word.
I was like, in fact, I really, um, I really need like, uh, I need your help because, um, when reps, uh, couldn't make it, um, they, they really want, we like had to give them a list of people.
And I was like, they really want to play with Hocus.
And I was like, in fact, like, please, can you please get Hocus in?
We, we really, really need Hocus in like, please.
And then in fact, like I stayed up till like 4am because like, um, 4 or 5am.
And then I, uh, I was just really happy that like, if I got back to me and he was like, I've got him.
And I was like, Oh, thank.
And then, but in fact was like, actually said yes a lot earlier, but I just forgot to tell you.
It's okay.
It's fine.
I just, I'm just happy.
I'm so sorry.
I just forgot to tell you.
So like, I was so happy that like, we, we actually got, um, we actually managed to get like, uh, like a backup in time, um, for, uh, Tsukumo's team.
I don't know.
I hope they had fun.
Um, did anyone who watched their POV, Hocus's, uh, team's POV, did they have fun?
I heard they were the passion English team because they really wanted to play with like NA slash EU pro.
Well, at first we were like NA only.
And then, um, and then like, we're like, okay, um, we, we can't be picky anymore.
So we'll just, so I hope that, um, Hocus's team, um, had fun with passion English with each other.
Um, so yeah, like, and for Hocus for literally being an emergency sub with less than 10 hours left.
So like when the tournament, when the custom started, it was, it was 3am for him.
So like, um, so, uh, I really, uh, I'm really happy that, uh, Hocus actually stayed, like, you know, played the custom at three in the morning on his end.
Also like, I'm sorry for this.
I don't know Tempo, what happened?
Why were servers being weird?
Like, and also like, I said an apology to Kuro because like, I was just like, I'm so sorry you had to play with 300 ping.
I'm really sorry.
Cause I didn't realize that, like, I don't know why we, Tempo was saying that like, um, it was supposed to be Oregon, but for some reason it was just not.
And Kuro was like, no, it's funny.
That's, it was like, no, it was really funny.
It's okay.
So, so, um, um, so like, uh, I had no idea why, why it was like, okay, but like, Ditto won.
So she won like 5, 1.5k.
And Kuro's like, no, no, it's fine.
Like it's actually, it was actually really funny.
Like, so, um, um, um, so like, I really appreciate it, even though like, like, I don't know why we specifically try to push for Oregon into the servers, but they kept swapping about the code.
Thank you for the five gift of ships.
Thank you.
Um, but yeah, um, honestly, like, um, it's such a, it was such a learning experience and I'm happy that in the end, like, um, everyone like had fun, um, and like had even the, you know, have a little bit fun too.
It was a great, a great thing as well.
Um, but yeah, I like, I think like if we could find a way to stabilize, I think like, I think honestly, just be easier to, if we want to invite JP and APAC people over again, I would say maybe it would be easier to put it at JP servers.
Um, but like, it depends on, but then like, that's the thing, like, I don't know, like, um, because like I said, like, we're screwing over one region over the other, because like APAC was the one that had to go with like the 200 to 300 ping and NA was fine,
um, because, you know, we were in NA.
Um, so it was honestly, like, you know, it's, it's, it's really hard to figure, because like, you know, if it was NA, then like, if we get to have it specifically in Oregon, then we fine.
Or we can like go back and forth.
I guess like in the future, if we do another APAC thing, we could swap servers back and forth.
So like one game will be in Oregon, the other one will be in JP, and then stuff like that.
So like, it might have tried to pull people, because we can test out a few servers days of, uh, a few servers days of before the games.
That's true, because we did sneak in EU players in.
It might have been like, well, but it was like three people.
We like, we sneaked three EU players in tempo, but I don't know how the fuck they changed the whole thing.
They, they changed the whole system.
Like, oh, three people fucked up the entire server.
Burrito, thank you for the akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, um, hi Doki.
Uh, I just want to know that the incredible effort and care you put into everything you do is very noticeable in seriously elevated the word dragoon from a simple fanbase to the title of January pile.
Thank you, I'm really happy.
Um, PSU tween that you've been slacking was wild.
Thank you, the akasupa, thank you, thank you.
What I meant by, like, slacking, as in like, I felt like I haven't been giving you guys enough, like, appreciation and gifts and stuff, because I know in the past I give you guys a lot of gifts and everything, and I felt like, oh my gosh, and like, you know,
I, the merch stuff is still, like, oh yeah, merch update.
We have everything.
We're shipping them but I'm sorry, you guys didn't know, Canada post is, um, Canada post is so shut down, so we can't ship products to Canada or international or outside of the, we can ship things only to the United States right now.
So, like, I don't know, things just keep going weird for me.
So, we have post office, post office has been shut down for, like, two plus months now and, like, we can only send things to the United States.
So, I'm sorry, we have everything now for the merch to start to, like, fix, ship the merch that we're so old.
Um, so, so, um, we just gotta wait until the post office strike is over and then it will be fine.
It'll be fine.
But yeah, like, I always want to show my appreciation for you guys.
I always want to show you guys that it really means a lot how much you guys care for me and, uh, uh, care for me and, like, support me through everything and, like, I know I have, like, so much stuff that's, like, been on the back burner and everything and I'm really sorry.
I'm really sorry.
That's why, like, there's, like, some stuff I haven't even shipped yet from the auction, from the charity auction, because of the post office strike when I finally got everything, like, postcards and everything signed and ready to send over.
The Canada post went on strike.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my god.
Um, but yeah, I just, things just sometimes just doesn't work out in the end, but I hope it fixes itself and I hope it fixes itself soon.
Um, Nisuga, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
He gave us already of us, uh, uh, enough already.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That really means a lot, guys.
Also, Hatch, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome.
Um, um, but yeah, like, thank you guys.
Um, I'm glad that the event, the custom, was a success.
Like, I, it's very serious talk, but like, it's more so of like, um, I guess, like, what's the word?
Um, just, uh, talking about, ah, what's the word?
Like, just going through what we, what we did and everything for the custom.
Um, what's that word?
Ah, it starts with an R, right?
Uh, just analyzing, like, a debrief, analyzing every, recap, sorry.
Yeah, the, this is a recap.
Just going through the recap of everything and, uh, retrospect, I guess, reflecting, yeah, reflecting, reflecting and reviewing, um, everything that, uh, uh, uh, that's been, uh, that we went through to get this to work.
And, um, yeah, like, I learned so much from Tempo on how he fucking does it.
Like, I straight up, when I was having my 57th breakdown over this custom, um, I was just like, how do you keep doing this every day?
Like, how do you, how do you do this to yourself?
Like, and he's like, you just gotta stop stressing out about it.
And I'm like, I can't, I care too much.
His blacklist is insane.
He has multiple blacklists.
Yes, yes, no, not one blacklist, multiple blacklists.
Um, um, but yeah, like, I, I do care.
I care too much.
Uh, that's why I care way too.
I care so much.
Um, I will be taking a little break before going into working on my next event because I have like a million things to catch up on.
Like, I have so much stuff that I'm behind on just because of this custom.
Like, instead of working on things I have to work on, I was working on this custom and I felt so bad.
I felt so bad.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry to my staff.
They're just like, you're supposed to work on this.
And I'm like, well, I was supposed to.
You're right.
I am supposed to work on this.
Um, Cas, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Hey Doki, I know you'll do even better next event.
Thanks for organizing such a fun event on my birthday.
Very proud of all the things you do.
I look forward to your content in the rest of this month.
Huge love.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
And happy birthday to you, Cas.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Cas.
Yeah.
Happy birthday.
Oh my God.
Oh yeah.
By the way, for those who don't follow me on Twitter, I posted a birthday artwork.
This artwork I had finished for months now.
I was going to make it into merchandise, but I wanted to fix my issue.
I don't want to milk you guys for merch and stuff because I want to fix my issues before I release merch because I want to make sure I have no backlog anymore for personal merch that I produce from my own personal store.
That's why I just decided to release it because I already have a new birthday art.
I don't want to reuse it for next year.
And I was like, just release it for today.
Today is just a normal day.
And I thought it was the perfect day to release the birthday art for free to everyone.
Just don't profit off of it.
You can make it into merch.
You can make it into an acrylic stand.
You can make it into a poster, a print, or anything.
Just don't sell it.
Don't monetize it or anything.
That's all that matters.
I think one of my mods can link it if they're online.
Link the birthday art that I released so you guys can make merchandise off of it in any way you want.
Like not merch, sorry.
You can make... I mean, yes, merch.
You can make your own personal merch off of it yourself.
Because I didn't want to, you know, I want to fix my... I want to make sure we had no more backlog.
I would have no more backlog regarding merchandising and stuff.
I mean, I have other stuff, but that's like from other companies.
That was from like other companies and stuff that's distributing it for us.
So like, I don't have to worry about it.
Like GamerStuffs and stuff like that.
Also, like I said, there's four more days left for GamerStuffs stuff.
So like, it really means a lot if you guys would be able to support via GamerStuffs because they do a lot regarding supporting me and supporting... and just, you know, they literally made the merch, like made the pins and the medals for free.
So yeah, like I said, huge shout out to GamerStuffs for the support on that.
I would love to have a Doki bird flavor.
I don't know what I would get, honestly.
I hope I made enough sales for it.
That's really it.
Also, you guys didn't see, I got nominated for a couple of stuff at the VTuber Awards.
So it really means a lot if you guys could vote for me for WrestleTuber, FPS, VTuber of the Year.
I don't fucking know if I'll actually get it because the competition is incredibly tough.
I haven't even tweeted out about it.
Wait, when does the voting close?
And also you guys got nominated too for Dragoon.
Okay, wait, when does it close, guys?
When does the voting close?
Because it's gonna be awkward if, like, I tweet about it and it closes.
Okay.
It doesn't even say!
Okay, let's just hope when I tweet it out tomorrow that it's still open.
Um, wait, they don't even say it!
Oh, fuck!
What?
They don't even say it!
Um, we can vote again.
I don't know.
Making a Google account is...
No, I'm joking.
I'm joking.
But yeah, anyway, also huge shout out to, uh, Wig and, uh, Greek for casting for free.
Uh, um, because, like, like I said, um, I really appreciate it.
They were like, you're- he was like, bro, bro, you're a homie.
Of course I'll do it for free because, uh, I was really worried about, like, um, if they would be able to do it or anything.
And, like, I was willing to pay them too.
I was like, no, it's okay.
I can pay you guys.
But they're like, no, no, you're a homie.
Like, and the fact that voter fraud in the stream- guys, guys, I'm not saying that you guys should commit voter fraud, but, like, I'm saying that, like, I bet other people do it, but I would not encourage it.
But, like, obviously you all have free will.
So, like, I can't stop you guys, but, like, it is frowned upon.
Oh,
man, it would be a shame if I planted an idea, like, in people's heads and, like, welcome to student council!
It's a fucking popularity contest.
Um,
um, what was I gonna say?
Uh, but, yeah, uh, I'm, like, I'm just, like, um, you know, like, post-event, uh, post-event emotions.
I'm just happy that, you know, things went okay.
Um, people had fun.
A lot of players were saying how much fun they had overall.
That's what I want.
I want people to have fun.
I want people to make memories.
Um, JP really liked it.
So, that's a bonus for me because I know that JP, either they know who I am and, like, they know who I am, but not, like, they know who I or they don't know who I am.
And, like, I'm happy that they enjoyed it.
And that, that means a lot.
I'm just, I'm just really, I'm just happy that they enjoyed the custom.
And that, um, um, um, and that Wig and Greek had a lot of fun, too.
I think they had fun nerfing people.
I think, I think, um, I think they, I'm glad that Wig and Greek had a lot of fun nerfing players and stuff and, like, terrorizing the NA pros in the scene.
Yeah.
Yeah, especially Greek.
Greek was coming up with all these fucking wild ass nerfs and stuff.
And me, I literally said, what do you guys want?
And then they're like, oh, we get to decide.
Oh, they were the ones that was, like, coming up with the fucking shit, the nerfs and everything.
What's fucked up was Tempo doxing my location to the hiders when I found my first victim.
That, that was fucked.
If anything was fucked up, that was the fucked up part.
Literally, literally, I finally found one guy and then Tempo was like, by the way, Doki's over here.
And I was like, what the?
And then that one guy I found fucking disappeared.
So, uh, so yeah, anyway.
So, um, that's why I, that was the thing I got mad about.
Okay, okay, I think, but then also it was really funny when I tricked several people into thinking I was a hider.
Like, I was like, why do you think a fucking hider would be a ballistic?
And then the fact that, like, people, several hiders thought I was, I was part of their team.
I was like, yes, yes.
You know where I got that idea from?
The very first hide and seek tournament with, and Timmy did that.
I think Timmy did, he didn't do that to me.
I think he did that to someone else.
And I remember that happening because I was watching it as a hider.
So thanks Timmy for teaching me the true strat.
Like, no, he did that.
He literally did that to, like, hiders.
And I, I literally stole his idea because I was like, oh, that's so evil.
I want to do that.
Like, that's, that's so fucking evil.
Um, so I'm glad I was able to pull that off.
Pull that off one time.
No, Chibidoki was felt so betrayed.
She was so excited to see.
I didn't know if that was just like, like, you know, I was just teabagging so they think I'm friendly.
Cause that's what I saw from, that's what I saw.
What, that's what I saw Timmy do.
That's what I saw Timmy do.
And I was like, oh my God, that's so evil.
Um, but I want to do.
I want to do it too.
Yeah, it's Timmy's fault.
It was, um, it was all Timmy's fault.
Um, that's right.
Um, I mean, he fucking won by being a princess.
Literally, we all saw him not shoot his fucking gun and then he won.
Like, all he did was he took a shield in a box, stood there, and then people around him fucking died.
Like, I was like, what the fuck?
Like, I was like, they just, they just fucking, the other guy just had a heart attack.
Like what happened?
What happened to the other guy?
Like, did he have a heart attack?
Like, next scene.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's my evil Oshie.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
He literally just existed.
Like, um, yeah.
Yeah, that was crazy to watch, but it was crazy to watch other players do like what they were doing and stuff.
It was insane.
Like, um, it was very crazy to watch it all happen.
Um, um, but yeah, I'm glad people had so much fun and I'm glad you guys enjoyed watching.
Um, I want to, my next event is definitely going to be an all VTuber event.
The next Apex event, I will be doing still, it's still going to be like, because you, it's, you can, it, not you can't, but it's even harder to get an all VTuber, um, custom, especially within NA.
Like, um, to be able to like, have, uh, especially to, it's very difficult to, to be able to get one of those, because like I said, in NA, it's a lot, uh, it's a lot different for Apex as well.
For FPS games, I think it's just more so FPS games in general.
Um, FPS games in general, um, it's hard to organize for an all VTuber FPS, uh, event in NA versus like one in like JP or like JP because there's more VTubers in JP side that's like more known, um, for FPS and everything.
Um, but like if I, like, um, because EA wants us to do it, do this again in the future.
Um, 60 people too.
Yeah, 60 people as well.
Um, but we will still go with the mixed format, um, until we have, there's more VTubers within FGC, um, IMO, I feel like there's more VTubers that's like willing, especially like the more like star power and stuff within FGC than there is for like specific FPS games.
So like, that's why it's just, it's very difficult.
Yeah, it's very difficult.
So like for definitely for future Apex events, it'll still be like a mixture of like Fleshies and VTubers, um, just because like to fill up the lobby and stuff.
And then like, um, especially when we want to be able to have sponsors and everything too.
Um, um, but we still try to invite like people from different backgrounds, different like backgrounds, different like view counts and everything like smaller indies, smaller companies and stuff like that.
And then bigger companies, bigger indies, we want to balance everything out.
Um, but yeah, like, um, FGC is definitely something I want to try out next time.
Um, because I know it's really popular in the VTubing community and I have messaged Sejam about it and stuff.
Obviously it's like, so at like, like we're just like, we just talked, like we just had exchanged like two or three messages, but then like I, it, I couldn't continue the messaging because I was busy with this fucking custom.
It's just ideas now and everything.
Um, but, um, um, yeah.
And, uh, definitely want to like look into like non-competitive stuff too.
My next event, it won't be super competitive and it'll be a full VTuber event.
Um, it'll be in 2025, obviously like nothing in December because like I'm already super packed in December.
Um, but 2025, where are in my next event that I want to try out would be something that's not super competitive and it will be an all VTuber event.
Um, I just hope people would still want to join.
I just hope people would still want to be part of it.
Um, no, web phishing is scary.
There's like a hacker going around in web phishing.
I don't know you guys, um, you guys like, uh, uh, know about the update, uh, regarding, uh, that, uh, web phishing.
There's like a hacker going around that's just like hacking into people's lobbies and banning them from people's lobbies.
And then there was, I don't know if it's like fixed though.
Is it over already?
Yeah.
There's like a bunch of people just...
Because it happened to Ruben.
He told me about it.
He was telling me that, uh, uh, some guy like went joined his lobby and then like doxxed his airport and stuff and like his viewers airports.
So like, I, I don't know if it's resolved or not, but like, I feel like, um, yeah.
And then he said he got like, he like, they like banned him from web, like they managed to like get him kicked out of webs phishing lobbies.
Yeah.
That's so scary.
Right?
I was like, what the fuck?
And he's like, yeah, this random guy.
And that was like last week.
So I don't know if it's like fixed already, but I, even then I wouldn't like test it out until like a couple, like maybe a month or two because like it might be patched, but like if they're really persistent, I feel like they would, um, I feel like they would try to keep,
they would keep trying it.
Um, yeah, they're still, yeah.
So like, that's why I'm like, I don't want to touch web phishing for now because, um, because of the, I thought I was insane.
I was like, what?
Like, I'm glad we managed to play web phishing when it first came out.
So people won't ruin the fun.
Like, like I'm just happy we were able to, um, we were able to play it like when it first came out.
So like, we didn't have to worry about that shit.
Cause like when we started playing it, like it was so new and like nothing, there was just like, you know, there wasn't anything like bad going on.
Cause people were just like phishing.
Yay!
We're all just like, yippee!
Phishing!
Little did we know, little did we know it was gonna talk about, it was gonna get worse.
We were so innocent back then.
We were like, yippee!
Phishing!
But yeah, yeah, I'm just, I had a great time in general guys.
Um, I always have a great time with my Dragoons and like, I just want to say thank you guys for always supporting me and supporting another successful event.
Um, every event I learn more and more.
Um, I feel like every event I get better at organizing.
Um, because each time I take what I learned from a previous event and improve it.
And I always try to, I know like my events are a little bit special because I push very hard for prizes and physical memorabilia.
Because like, I know like streaming wise, um, you know, um, we're creating memories from stream.
I always thought that like having something physical that you get from it, um, means so much to people.
Especially like, even with the little thing, like the little pins I'm giving people, because you know, we are not going to be content creators forever.
Um, I know you guys are like, I'm going to watch you when you're fucking 80.
But like, silly you guys, I live forever.
I'll never be 80.
But like, um, I don't know, girls are ageless.
Uh, anyway, um, so like I try to push for physical prizes because, you know, when you, you know, maybe like 20 years down the line and you see like something you want in this silly little like apex event or the wrestling event and you like think back to and be like,
Oh my God, yeah, I was part of this event that like this person organized and like, like, like, like seeing a memorabilia, I always think like seeing a memorabilia is like, like something physical that you can get from it.
And then you just like brings back memories and stuff like, you know, I used to, you know, I did sports a lot and I would have like prizes and trophies and stuff like that.
And then, you know, you know, I want, you know, I got like MVP, but had the physical medal of me getting MVP.
And it was always was really close to my heart because I was like, I did that.
I had had that experience.
So like, it's always like I want people like especially VTubers to be like, I was pushed for it.
And I would be like, you know, you've managed to get this physical item.
And you can look back to it and be like, Oh my God, like, um, this was something I participated like 20 years ago.
And like, these are the memories I get looking at this and stuff versus like, you know, watching a VOD back because like, you know, I'd rather be able to have like something physical that you could look at it like physical trinkets and stuff like reminders of like what you've done in your streaming career and things like that.
And it's like a little collection too.
So like, you know, everybody who participates gets a little enamel pin as like a little collection, you know, every time maybe like you're you joined various events I've hosted and you have like a little collection of like these pins that you've you've like collected from me and stuff like that,
like a Pokemon trainer, like a gym leader.
So I, I try to push that a lot.
And I hope that every event I do will have some form of like physical prize or like physical trophy medals or like pins and stuff that I can give out to people.
Um, but yeah, anyway, thank you guys so much for coming.
Um, I really appreciate everybody for supporting me for this long.
And it's almost the end of the year.
It's almost the end of 2025 2024.
Sorry, fucking math numbers.
I'm not dinner yet, guys.
I don't know if that's noticeable.
But um, it's almost the end of 2024.
I feel like we've accomplished so much within like how many months has it been since I came back 12345678910.
In 10 months, we've done in 10 months, we have organized two big events, WrestleTuber and the Apex Custom.
We have our concert that's in two weeks.
No, in less than two weeks, we have a Nendoroid preorders that are coming out very, very soon.
We have done so many dream sponsors, we're going to be in we were in video, we got in game cosmetics, like being in Rust, having our very own personal Rust skin, we won multiple tournaments.
Under Doki Bird, we got nominated for vtuber of the year in two separate award nominations, we got nominated for two different vtubers of the year, even though I would have preferred gamer of the year and the other.
If I was given two, because like, you know, the other one was like, wow, Doki, it's so entitled.
I'm just saying, I'm just saying, because I, you know, the limit was two.
If I get to choose the limit, like choose between because I know I definitely could have been nominated for gamer of the year, but there's a two, there's a, there's a two limit.
I'm just saying.
If I win FPS, I should be gamer too.
Anyway.
We got that, we got, what else did we do?
We did, we did so many amazing collabs.
We've interacted with so many amazing people within 10 months.
And like we did, like, I think I did like eight plus conventions within 10 months, which is really crazy.
I'm gonna post photos of the other conventions too, because I know I stopped posting photos because I was so over, there was just so many things going on that I keep forgetting to post like recasts of conventions and everything.
We raised $256,000 for charity, which I have to still send out some of the stuff from the charity stuff.
So I'm really sorry if you're still waiting for those.
We got our own PC case and PC cast with Hyatt.
There's so many things we've accomplished within 10 months.
And it's actually really crazy that we were able to do all of this together.
And I really appreciate all of you guys for supporting me and like taking me this far and everything.
Hey guys, enough mushy stuff.
It's time to call it because I'm tired.
As always everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stand for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
And thank you again for always supporting me and for helping me make this event successful.
I really appreciate it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye!